welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and captain america steve rogers
says another thing he can do all day and
that is putting america's ass on a
mission she-hulk episode one ended with
i think my favorite mcu post-credit
moment ever captain america [ __ ]
yes but who the question of who punched
cap's v card feels like a mystery
perfectly tailored for me and not just
because i asked the question before on
this channel and yes you may have seen
me on social media mounting this one
like steve on a loose grenade and i am
not sorry about that but in this video i
am going to go even deeper into the list
of suspects though not as deep as steve
did i am sorry for that one the question
of steve rogers virginity comes up early
in she-hulk episode 1 and even
contributes to jen walter's car crash
that leads to her power-up steve rogers
did not have a girlfriend before he went
into the service
says who
did the history channel obviously
captain america wasn't portraiture
jen brings it up again in the
post-credits scene pretending to be
drunk to get the answer out of bruce did
you see that ass like that ass did not
deserve to diverge it's feeling so sad
steve rogers is not a virgin
he lost his virginity to a girl in 1943
on the uso tour and in the closing
credits we see jen with an eric vos
style stringboard breaking down the
suspects of caps first steve in the
middle in his uso tour costume to his
left howard stark's search vessel in
1945 looking for steve's crash valkyrie
aircraft in the polar ice below that
peggy carter's file photo then an image
of a uso dancer and costumed with a blue
hat and then an arrow from her pointing
to a faceless woman with short lighter
hair and between peggy and the uso
dancer a yellow piece of paper with a
question mark on it now we don't know
who the faceless woman in the upper
right is or who the question mark refers
to but we can narrow down the options by
the way chris evans himself reacted to
this episode tweeting some emojis
including one for my lips are sealed and
she hulk head writer jessica gao
confirmed that marvel head kevin feige
told her the true canonical answer to
this question meaning the truth is out
there it is known cap does have a burst
so we must start with the obvious
suspect here steve rogers soul mate
bucky barnes don't do anything stupid
till i get back how can i
you're taking all this stupid with you
because i'm with you at the end of the
line ah no sadly while it is head canon
for many of you that these two buds were
howling commandos off screen what do you
mean by that
bucky is probably not the mystery cherry
popper bruce banner was referring to at
least according to whatever popular lore
he heard of some girl on the uso tour in
1943. so what about steve's beard
forever dance partner peggy carter peggy
carter at least mentally made a man out
of steve when he slid out of that oven
but the buns were too hot to handle and
these two always get room for jesus
between them until steve went into the
ice really steve's disappointment upon
waking up says it all i had a date
does this look like the face of a man
who's satisfied moving on to our next
suspect you may remember natalie dormir
as private lorraine in the strategic
scientific reserve in london the women
of america they owe you their thanks
[Music]
and uh
seeing as they're not here
but agent carter comes in with the block
and considering peggy tries to murder
the first avenger after this she didn't
know the shield would block the bullets
i doubt it went any further than that
between steve and private lorraine not
to mention steve's running with lorraine
came after steve's rescue and the
celebratory drinks in that pub showed a
poster confirming steve's uso tour was
cancelled at that point so this could
not have happened on the tour remember
jen walter's stream board includes a uso
dancer with the blue cap if you've
re-watched the star-spangled man with
the plan montage in that 2011 film a
number of dancers match that description
there's a woman with burdette hair
saluting to the left of steve she shows
up a few times during the sequence like
when he walks down the line there are
actually two ladies who seem to be
saluting him in particular i think these
are the same two that that hitler actor
sneaks behind and after steve dex hitler
these two can be seen on the right
really making a meal out of showing him
their gratitude what else could they be
thanking him for and let us not overlook
that dancer in the back who at the start
of this montage peeks back at steve
through the curtain as our star spangled
man is getting into his costume what was
she hoping to see or maybe get a second
look at i am skeptical that steve hooked
up with any of the dancers on this tour
steve was just too much of an awkward
sad sack but more importantly too much
of a gentleman to hook up with his
co-workers and deal with the drama
traveling city to city today's video is
sponsored by babel one of the top
language learning apps in the world
we've all got a language we want to
learn for me it is spanish i would love
to go on a food trip to mexico it'd just
be nice to know more spanish when i do
than just taco's apostol before i mean
sure that is the most important phrase
but you know i just get the sense that
there are a few other phrases that'd be
good to know too things like can i have
more tacos please and will you let me
live in your taqueria and that is what
babel is for babel specializes in
preparing you for real life encounters
and situations studies have shown that
15 hours of using babel is the
equivalent of a semester of college in
spanish and 15 hours in babble just
flies by i can watch videos listen to
podcasts play games or do lessons
whatever kind of learning mood i'm in
babel's got something that fits the bill
i like how they gamify learning i have
daily goals and achievements that i can
unlock as i learn the language now i'm
pretty early in my battle journey but i
have started to learn some useful
phrases like may trae la quentapo
which is how you ask for the check after
eating roughly 20 tacos it's gonna be a
good trip get up to 60 off your babble
subscription when you click the link in
the description to start learning with
babble today however there is a woman
steve meets while he's on the tour whom
steve definitely has eyes for this adult
fan girl after meeting so many kids
asking for autographs finally he meets
one his age
right there that is what we call a
double take and it's what a fella does
when he's ready to double down the
crucial piece of evidence here is the
camera flash that means there is
photographic evidence of these two
meetings marvel studios has had an
insanely detailed continuity with the
photographs taken of steve during this
period his 4f file photo from camp
lehigh stays framed on peggy's desk and
in-game the famous photo of steve
holding that lucky star cab company dora
is a shield seen in the smithsonian
exhibit in the falcon of the winter
soldier the 2011 film actually included
a woman in the crowd snapping a photo
from exactly that angle so it just makes
sense that whatever photo taken of steve
and this fan girl would have also become
part of his mythology something seen
during this period by say howard stark
mentioned among his obsessive drunken
stories over the years about how awesome
captain america was to his son tony
leaving tony with his famous inferiority
complex and probably mentioned by tony
over drinks to bruce banner during the
blip in mexico as bruce indicated they
did yeah me and tony
now tony mostly drank just sat around
complaining about steve so this gives us
a clear chain of gossip for how bruce
banner would even know how steve lost
his virginity by the way it's also
interesting that bruce banner says steve
rogers is not a virgin suggesting that
steve might still be alive in the mcu
and bruce banner might know where he is
but anyway we should also point out this
fan girl is played by laura haddock who
also in the mcu plays peter quill's
mother meredith quill in the guardians
of the galaxy movies james gunn was
asked about this connection in 2018 and
he did jokingly speculate that the cap
fan girl could have been peter quill's
grandmother meredith's mother actors
from that 2011 captain america film have
come back to play their descendants
before kenneth choi played jim morita
and his grandson principal morita in
spider-man homecoming evidenced by that
principle's framed photo of grandpa jim
in his office the most city steve had
visited during this montage by the time
he met this fan girl was chicago the
closest of the cities listed to missouri
where meredith lived as a young woman
and the timeline almost works peter
quill was conceived in 1980 and if
meredith was 36 then she would have been
born in 1944 nine months after this
woman met steve i know you're gonna say
36 might be a bit old for a woman to
have kids in the year 1980 but i don't
know laura haddock was around 31 when
she shot that ego flashback scenes for
guardians vol 2. so uh it would just
track for kevin feige to consider this
canon he previously retconned the kid
tony stark saved in iron man 2 as a
young peter parker also behind the
scenes when they were casting steve
rogers feige and his casting director
sarah haley finn the true mvp of the mc
if you ask me they brought in chris
pratt to audition for the role of steve
rogers clearly marvel studios has always
seen these two chris's as similar types
so could steve rogers be peter quill's
biological grandfather and that
grandfather we met played by greg henry
who consoles peter in the hospital
perhaps meredith's stepfather could it
be that in addition to being the son of
a celestial that star-lord could also be
the grandson of a super soldier in the
first avenger i mean i don't know folks
james gunn's long-lost easter egg and
the first guardians of the galaxy has
yet to be fully decoded but we know for
sure that it has something to do with
peter quill's mother and one of the
things james gunn said that we were
definitely on the right track about is
the fact that his guardians movies have
been obsessed with the concept of
dancers versus non-dancers peter quill
is a dancer meredith quill also a dancer
steve rogers before he goes into the ice
remember tells peggy that he cannot
dance and suggest to have the band play
something slow and the last we see him
in the mcu he finally gets that dance
i've said it once and i will say it
again the whole mcu is a dance-off to
save the universe but whether or not
steve hooking up with this fan girl led
to a pregnancy and to beat her quill i
still think she is the one who punched
the card let me know what you think and
follow me on tiktok instagram and
twitter at eavos subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you